well in 1994-1995 I began reading that
they were going to do a movie Merchant
Ivory was going to be doing a movie
about Jefferson called Jefferson and
Paris and there was a lot of
consternation on the part of people
because they heard that they were going
to treat the story is true the story
that Jefferson had a liaison with Sally
Hemings that was going to be
incorporated into the film and they were
saying things like there's no evidence
that this ever happened and you know
Jefferson would never be involved with
the slave girl and I sort of wondered
you know of all the things that you know
people make question in history why was
it so important for people to vote - you
know - so vociferously deny that this
was possible and if you if you're gonna
you know you shouldn't believe this
above anything else about American
history and so I sat down to write an
op-ed piece that kind of got longer and
longer and longer and then I decided to
go ahead and write a book about it not
about whether or not Jefferson and
Hemings had children together but
whether or not but how people wrote
about it how blacks words are perceived
how blacks are portrayed in the pages of
history because I thought there was a
real double standard in looking at the
evidence for the relationship versus the
statements of Jefferson's family you
know their explanation for why all these
kids looked at like Jefferson so there
wasn't there were issues of race and
issues of class that really interested
me and I wanted to try to tease that out
more than did he did they or didn't they
but it was really about the
historiography of the subject
for this particular book Jefferson's
papers are being published all of them
aren't published yet his letters I mean
there are you know thousands and
thousands of them he his memorandum-book
his list list of all his transactions
that's been published the farm book has
been published as well that's his record
of life on plantation life at Monticello
um so those things are published there
are unpublished archives you know if I
go to the the Jefferson Papers I used
some unpublished papers as well but I
looked at archives in in Virginia the
Virginia Historical Society the Library
of Virginia I went to England for some
of the material about Sally Hemings his
father a couple of London and Lancashire
so all over
well when I figured out that I should be
paying attention to the names of Sally
hemings's children I was sort of going
along and with my first book just sort
of writing them down and going through
and doing this various things and then I
began to wonder well you know these are
actual I began to see other randolph
people who had the same name and then I
began to think who are these people why
are these children named and what does
Beverly come from well Wigan Beverly was
actually Jefferson's oldest son's name
who is that that was actually a person
and so and when I found out who that was
and I found out that he was an associate
of Jefferson's father that they had been
on an expedition together they had
carved their initials and a tree
together but then it just hit me here's
something that's right in front of your
face the names of these children
something that and if they had been
married at Jefferson and Hemings have
been married you would say oh of course
look at their children's names but
because they don't have that legal
relationship I was just sort of looking
in the eye and everybody else was just
sort of looking at this like it was
meaningless and it turns out to be
something that's right in front of your
nose that's incredibly meaningful and so
then I found out who Thomas estin was
who Harriet was we know who James
Madison was Madison Hemings his name was
James Madison and who William Beverly
was so it was like an epiphany to me at
that moment aha moment where you realize
you know it's and it's always like that
it's never any sort of convoluted Rube
Goldberg thing the simplest thing stick
with the simple things
what are they named what are her
children's names and how what is their
relationship to Jefferson so that was a
real a ha moment for me and that's when
I really was working on the first book
when I began to get the sense that this
is true because when I went into it I
really did not know what I was going to
find I was writing about what people had
written about the story and then when I
saw that I was like oh that really
changed my whole attitude about this
you